You guys, the U.S. Open
is this week,
and their partner, Heineken,
wants to help bring
more New Yorkers to the open.
-That's right, Seth.
-Oh, I'm sorry everybody.
This is one of my writers,
John Lutz.
Lutz, why are you wearing that?
-I just got back
from the U.S. Open.
-You just got back?
You realize you were supposed
to be working today?
-I know, but why would I do that
when Heineken is having
this really fun promotion?
Want me to tell you about it?
-Now?
-When else?
[ Laughter ]
The Heineken US Bus
drove around New York
during the U.S. Open and brought
New Yorkers to see it for free,
and it just so happened that I
scored one of those seats.
Man, oh man, you should have
seen me play.
-Wait, I thought the bus was
just taking you
to watch the U.S. Open,
not play in it.
-Well, that's where
you're wrong
because I played doubles.
Right, Wally?
-That's right.
-Ugh.
Not you too, Wally?
-What?
Lutz and I won mixed doubles.
-That's not how
any of this works.
-Yes, it is.
Seth, come on, you're giving us
zero love.
-Advantage Lutz.
-Ugh!
[ Laughter ]
Stop with the tennis puns.
Heineken reminds you
that Heineken cans
are the best choice
for warm-Weather settings,
so drink Heineken.
-And be sporty like me!
Wink!
[ Tink! ]
-And me. Wink!
-Why do you wink
and say "wink?"
You don't need to do both.
-Got it.
Wink!
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
-We'll be right back with more
"Late Night," everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪